good morning Hank it's Tuesday so every
January I write myself two letters one
looking back at the year that was and
one setting a series of goals for the
year to come and over the last 10 years
these letters have become a big deal to
me they help me to reflect and also to
try to make conscious choices about my
life and they've also helped me to
achieve lots of goals from running half
marathons to writing novels but this
year I'm thinking about the letters a
little differently I'm focusing on
beginnings and endings what do I want to
begin and what do I want to end or
finish let's start there so first this
year I will finish our crash course in
European history which has been great
fun and has taught me so much about how
to shift perspectives when studying
history but it is going to end because
we are approaching the present and also
there are a couple other creative
projects I'd like to wrap up this year
but I can't talk about those publicly
yet most importantly in 2020 I would
like to finish raising the twenty
million dollars that partners and health
needs in order to break ground on the
maternal center of excellence which will
dramatically improve the health care
options available to women and children
in Sierra Leone thousands of you have
become monthly donors to that project at
PIH org slash Hank and John and I am so
grateful and so are people in Sierra
Leone of course one of whom made me this
amazing artwork but we still need to
raise a few million dollars which I
realize is a lot of money and maybe 2020
isn't a realistic goal for it but it's
my goal by the way if you can make a big
donation to Partners in Health please
email me at sparks fly up at gmail.com
or just donate directly to the matching
fund there is a link in the doobly-doo
the last thing I want to finish is
writing a book not necessarily a novel
but some kind of book all right on the
beginnings I would like to begin no
longer working at night or on the
weekends which I guess is also a way of
saying I would like to end the practice
of working at night or on the weekends
which makes me think that in some ways
every new beginning leads to some other
beginnings and but now I'm quoting the
band Semisonic by way of the stoic
philosopher Seneca we've got to get out
of this tailspin made a mega bright to
keep this goal specific measurable and
achievable I want to work no more than
one night per week and never on the
weekends except for when I'm traveling
for work like this weekend when I will
be in st. Petersburg Atlanta and Raleigh
on tour with Hank come see us I think
shows is sold out but come see us at the
other ones links in the dooblydoo a very
exciting beginning Sara's book you are
an artist comes out in April and the
galleys are here it's a wonderful
collection of art assignments and
creativity prompts with lots of art
history it's just so great and I'm so
excited and it's available for pre-order
now also hanky your book of beautifully
foolish endeavor which is such a good
title comes out in July and I will be
touring with both you and Sara in the
hopes of helping those books have good
beginnings so a lot of travel this year
which means I gotta take good care of my
body and my brain which is part of my
body slightly off topic but what a weird
thing it is to have a mind made out of
body last beginning I would like to
write one thank-you note every day for
the entire year I did this for a month
back in November and it helped me so
much it made me feel more grateful and
less pessimistic I got the idea from an
82 year old woman who wrote me a
thank-you note and explained the project
that she was doing but then I lost her
address so I can't thank her back so
maybe she's watching thank you there are
also several things I don't want to
begin or end but instead want to
continue like exercising at least 150
minutes per week making dear Hank and
John every Monday making a vlog brothers
video every Tuesday and not losing large
swaths of my life to scrolling through
Twitter as dread washes over me I'm
curious what you'd like to begin and and
continue in 2020 and what you see when
you look back at your 2019 so let's
continue the conversation in comments
before I go one thing I hope you will
begin this year the nerdfighteria census
which is so so helpful to us in
determining the priorities of our
community and what you would like us to
do together you can find a link to it in
the doobly-do and in the comments below
Hank it is a great pleasure to say in a
third decade I will see you on Friday